nous passons ensuite à l'article diter
avec quatre amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion nous commençons une
discussion commune nous commençons par
deux amendements identiques le premier
et le 377 madame Goulet vous avez la
parole bonjour monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre l'article 10 est
issu d'un amendement du Gouvernement à
l'Assemblée nationale et consiste à
modifier le régime de la TVA applicable
au secteur hôelier au locations
touristiques dont nous avons déjà
beaucoup parlé cet amendement propose de
soumettre à la TVA les locations de
meublés de tourisme le seuil de
franchise de TVA serait abaissé à 5000 €
de recette annuelle pour ce type
d'activité merci chers collègues
l'amendement 1339 n'est pas défendu en
séance ensuite deux amendements
identiques nous commençons par le 256
monsieur
Brisson vous avez la parole chers collè
merci monsieur le Président c'est av un
petit peu différent simplement par la le
seuil de franchise qui est plus élevé je
voudrais just juste placer quelques
éléments forts et nous avons beaucoup
parlé il y a de jours des effets des
locations saisonnières via les
plateformes sur la crise du logement
c'est une autre dimension qui est ici
posée c'est la concurrence largement
déloyale vis-à-vis des hébergeur
professionnel de l'hôtellerie en
particulier actuellement contrairement
aux hôtels les locations de tourisme ne
sont soumises à TVA que si elles
assurent au moins trois prestations
parahôtelières parmi les quatre
suivantes le service de petit-déjeuner
le service de nettoyage régulier la
fourniture de l'ING de maison et la
réception de la clientèle authentique y
sont très rarement assujéti par un avis
du 5 juillet le Conseil d'État reconnu
que ce n'était pas conforme au droit
communautaire et créé de fate une
distorsion de concurrence le
gouvernement est donc tenu d'y mettre un
terme pour autant au lieu d'assujettir à
la TVA les locations de meublés de
tourisme le gouvernement a proposé au
contraire d'étendre le M modèle Airbnb
au secteur de l'hôtellerie avec les
risques que cela comporte l'invitation à
l'émergence d'hôtel sans service la
baisse de qualité du service hôtelier la
réduction du nombre d'emplois dans
l'hôtellerie de de surtout cette mesure
est finalement un subterfuge puisqu'elle
consiste à continuer d'exonérer les
locations de tourisme à la TVA aussi je
propose un amendement qui vise d'une
part à sujettir la TVA les loocations de
mobblet de tourisme et d'autre part à
abaisser le seuil de la franchise de la
TVA à 15000 € annuel pour ce type
d'activité serait ainsi mis fin à la
distorsion de concurrence observée en
appliquant le modèle de l'hôtellerie aux
locations de meublé de tourisme et non
l'inverse et par conséquent de garantir
une concurrence saine entre les
différents moyens d'hébergement
touristique sans inciter à une baisse
éventuelle de la qualité des services
proposés merci chers collègu monsieur
brossa vous défendez le
526 merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre dans dans le même sens que
que mes collègues Nathalie Goulet et Max
Brisson on l'a dit ici ce vendredi nous
avons en France une fiscalité qui est
outrentièrement favorable aux
plateformes de location touristique au
détriment du logement nous en avons
parlé vendredi et nous y avons
d'ailleurs remédié par le vote de nos
amendements au détriment de l'hôtellerie
aussi puisqueaujourd'hui vous allez à
l'hôtel vous payez la TVA vous allez
dans un logement Airbnb vous ne payez
pas la TVA sauf dans des conditions bien
particulières tout ça est proprement
ahurissant et nous souhaitons mettre un
mettre un terme à cette distorsion de
concurrence et c'est l'objet de cet
amendement merci chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur général quel est
votre avis sur les deux amendements
identiques 377 et 1339 là je pense que
chacun convient que le le dispositif et
les règles fiscales
aujourd'hui doivent être modifiées mais
pour tout vous dire dire je n'ai pas
trouvé dans les dans les amendements
d'ailleurs qui sont différents ou
différenciés euh de solutions
qui paraissent alors je ne sais pas il
faut faire attention au mot utiliser
mais qui apparaîtrait raisonnable et
éventuellement efficace euh ce qui me
paraît par contre important d'où les
demandes de retrait pour l'ensemble des
amendements mais ce qui me paraît
important monsieur le ministre on l'a
dit avant-hier dans nos débats c'est de
comment dirais-je de
procéder
rapidement à l'issue de la mission hein
parce que qui a été confié donc à à à
deux
députés pour sur une une véritable
remise à plat de ce dispositif pour
regarder de quelle manière entre les
meublés l'hôtellerie euh Airbnb pour ne
pas les citer comment on regarde les
règles avec également on a une peut-être
une singularité c'est de faire attention
à ne pas à être comment dirais- respueux
de de l'égalité des des uns et des
autres devant l'impôt merci Monsieur le
Ministre la vie du gouvernement sur ces
quatre
amendements merci monsieur le Président
bonjour à toutes et et à tous ça sera un
avis défavorable pour pour deux raisons
deux raisons principales la première
c'est que en soumettant à
à la TVA les locations meublées ce que
vous souhaitez faire vous ouvrez aussi
parce que c'est le principe même de la
TVA la déductibilité à la TVA pour
celles et ceux qui font de la location
en meublé je donne un exemple vous êtes
un propriétaire qui veut investir pour
faire de la location meublée demain si
je suis votre amendement ces revenus
seront soumis c'est revenu oui c'est ça
soumis à TVA mais s'il a procédé à
l'acquisition de son logement à la
rénovation de son logement vous allez
lui offrir un droit à déductibilité de
la TVA ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui je ne pense pas que ce soit
l'intention de votre amendement mais
c'est vraiment un effet de bord majeur
de votre vous ouvrez le droit à
déductibilité de la TVA pour tout un
secteur qui ne l'a pas aujourd'hui et et
dont on peut penser grâce avec ce
dispositif qui pourront aussi un peu
optimiser euh le le leur le dispositif
bon donc premier argument de fond c'est
que là on on crée un dispositif
finalement très généreux qui est la
conséquence directe de votre de votre
amendement deuxième sujet vous
souhaitez
pouvoir remonter les seuils enfin
baisser les seuils pour les seules
activité de location meublée franchise
de TVA c'est impossible de le cibler sur
une seule activité seuils de franchise
de TVA aujourd'hui ces seuils sont pour
tous les secteurs confondus on ne peut
pas dans le droit dire le seuil
franchise de TVA je le fais uniquement
pour les locations meublées ce serait
complètement contraire au droit
européens où ces seuils sont pour toute
tout type d'entreprise donc pour ces
deux raisons-là et si je comprends
l'intention je pense que cet amendement
ne concourt pas l'objectif que que que
vous défendez donc c'est un c'est un
avis défavorable merci monsieur le
ministre je mets au voix l'amendement
oui excusez-moi monsieur brissant vous
avez la parole merci merci monsieur le
président
moi je crois cher rapporteur général que
la raison c'est d'essayer de faire
disparaître cette distorsion de
concurrence qui aujourd'hui pèse
beaucoup sur les hôteliers par rapport
aujourd'hui à des résidences qui sont
peu à peu transformés en location
saisonnière qui s'apparentent à des
hôtels sans les contraintes ni fiscales
ni de norm de l'hôtel c'est bien là mon
combat mon combat c'est est par rapport
à ceux qui dans des cités touristiques
achète peu à peu des immeubles tout
entiers les transformment en hôtel de
fait et ne sont ni assujettis à la TVA
ni à respecter les normes de la TVA
alors je veux bien que mon amendement a
des faiblesses nous avons parlé vendredi
soir mais il a cet objectif là qui je
crois est un objectif louable d'équité
parce qu'il rend la situation de plus en
plus insupportable pour de nombreux
hôteliers un peu partout sur le
territoire vous avez parlé à juste titre
monsieur le ministre de la déduction qui
serait possible mais aujourd'hui en sens
inverse je vous ferai remarquer que avec
les décisions que vous avez pris
beaucoup de structures hôtelière pouront
demander à être exonéré de la TVA donc
la situation que vous avez décidé après
l'arrêté du Conseil d'État crée aussi un
effet de bord qui ne semble pas vous
gêner alors que vous avez pointé le mien
moi je crois que ce qui est appelé par
cet amendement c'est vraiment la
recherche d'une égalité de traitement
par rapport des activités d'hébergement
qui se ressemblent de plus en plus du
côté de l'hôtellerie où un certain
nombre de services vont être vont
disparaître vis-à-vis des décisions que
vous avez prises et du côté de de
location saisonnière qui prennent un
caractère commercial de plus en plus
affiché à travers une véritable
spéculation sur les résidences sur les
meublés de tourisme merci Monsieur
brossa pour explication de
vote merci dans le droitfil de ce que
vient de dire Max Brisson vous trouvez
toujours des raisons de ne rien faire
face à la prolifération de ces locations
touristiques
systématiquement et ce ne sont pas des
arguments ce sont des prétextes et je
vous le dis amendement après amendement
ça finit par se voir et ça finit comment
dire par interroger on finit même par
trouver ça troublant cette volonté coûte
que coûte de défendre ces plateformes de
location touristique alors même que des
élus de tout bord de toute région vous
alertent sur les ravages provoqués par
ces locations touristiques et sur la
situation du logement et en raison de la
concurrence déloyale qu'elle crée
vis-à-vis du secteur hôelier honnêtement
ça
interroge et je pense qu'il est grand
temps que nous prenions nos
responsabilités et que nous mettions un
terme à ces distorsions de concurrence
insupportable ministre vous avez la
parole
je voudrais merci monsieur le Président
revenir sur l'intervention précédente du
sénateur Brisson vous dire que quand
vous a de la location meublée qui offre
des services comparables à l'hôtellerie
ce que vous le point que vous soulevez
par exemple petit-déjeuner c'est le même
régime fiscal de l'hôtellerie qui
s'applique dans ce
cas allez-y Monsieur Je je vais essayer
de finir de ma réponse et je reviendrai
vers vous monsieur Bonsin donc ce que je
veux dire par là c'est que le régime
fiscal il existe après est-ce qu'il y a
des locations meublées qui offrent des
prestations équivalente à l'hôtellerie
mais sur le fond sur le fond c'est moi
c'est ma responsabilité on a eu ce débat
un peu vigoureux vendredi soir pour vous
dire attention l'amendement que vous
proposez je vous l'ai dit l'autre jour
vous avez touché un certain nombre de
situation logement étudiant résidence de
service en augmentant énormément la
fiscalité c'est juste ma responsab de
vous le dire et sur cet amendement ma
responsabilité de vous dire que vous ne
pouvez pas avoir un seuil différent pour
la location meublée qui distinguerit la
location moblée du reste ce n'est pas
possible je suis désolé de le dire et ce
n'est pas juste une conviction
personnelle c'est l'application du droit
ce n'est pas possible et attention quand
on soumet à la TVA on ouvre la porte à
la déductibilité ce qui peut-être des
sommes considérables et à la fin une
subvention directement de l'État
puisqueavec les taux de TVA à tau réduit
entre la collecte et la déductibilité
vous pouvez avoir de fait un régime très
favorable à ceux qui en bénéficient donc
ma responsabilité c'est vous alerter sur
ces deux grands risques qui qui sont
portés par votre amendement monsieur
brossa comment pouvez-vous dire ça ben
je donc je vais vous répondre d'abord
est-ce qu'on a avancé sur le sujet des
plateformes l'obligation de transmission
des revenus de la plateforme au aux
finances publiques permettant de mieux
collecter la taxe de séjour ça
n'existait pas on l'a fait est-ce qu' on
a proposé ici ça a été voté de revenir
sur la niche fiscale à 71 %. la
proposition on l'a fait est-ce qu'on a
permis on a étendu le nombre de communes
pour augmenter la taxe d'habitation sur
les résidences secondaires 2 tiers des
résidences secondaires sont désormais
dans un périmètre où les élus peuvent
augmenter la taxe d'habitation sur les
résidents secondaires on l'a fait est-ce
qu'on a augmenté la taxe sur les
logements vacan et la déliaison des taux
entre taxes d'habitation sur les
résidences secondaires taxes foncièes je
je je vous rebrosse je vous si vous
permettez je vous réponde monsieur
brossa vous avez beau je vous réponds je
sais que ça vous est désagréable mais je
vous réponds quand même donc l'idée
queil y aurait un espèce de plan caché o
on ne voudrait rien faire c'est vos
insinuations un peu douteuses monsieur
brossa et s s'agissant de la politique
fiscale vous en avez fait une belle de
politique fiscale quasi quasi
révolutionnaire d'ailleurs donc
franchement à d'autrre les leçons merci
je peux mettre au voie cet amendement
300 77 qui a qui a reçu un avis de
retrait de la commission un avis
défavorable de du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre il n'est pas adopté je mets
ensuite au voit les deux amendements
identiques 256 et 526 qui ont reçu un
avis de retrait de la commission un avis
défavorable du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre ils sont adoptés
et ces amendements emportent une
nouvelle rédaction de l'article 10 TER
que je ne mets donc pas au
voix